un autre geste qui est devenue virale
sur facebook depuis quelques jours
mettre en ligne de photos de soi prise à
dix ans d'écart
de quoi comparer ses coupes de cheveux
ou encore leurs couleurs pour les
usagers de facebook c'est une façon
plutôt ludique de constater que le temps
passe vite et que tout le monde change
des rêves qui se réalisent ou encore la
vie qui passe pour maman et fils tonnes
10 ans plus tard le tout hollywood
n'échappe pas non plus à ce défi même
kateline jenner qui il y a dix ans était
encore bruce et c'est devenu viral aussi
à la télévision quand sont pas très
transparent justement c'est parce qu'ils
vont faire l'index selon alain mckenna
ce défi virale pour facebook c'est une
bonne façon de récolter davantage de
données sur vous les usagers tout ça
afin de perfectionner l'intelligence
artificielle de plus en plus présents
sur le web
le contexte est même l'action sont des
choses qu'on essaie de développer très
activement labo des idées de facebook
google et des autres et par action ça
peut inclure le vieillissement même son
action très lent qu'on s'entend car ne
pouvoir reconnaître les traits du visage
qui change qui évolue dans le temps pour
une intelligence artificielle
c'est extrêmement intéressant de le
femme ça peut donner aussi extrêmement
lucratives pour facebook
ces kits o'neal experte en technologie
qui a jeté le premier pavé dans la mare
cette semaine elle se demande comment
toutes ces données apparemment
inoffensive peuvent être utilisés pour
entraîner les algorithmes de
reconnaissance faciale au processus de
vieillissement
la reconnaissance faciale c'est l'une
des technologies les plus recherchés et
que les entreprises essayent toujours de
raffiner un exemple concret de ces
progresser dans des restaurants où il
suffit maintenant de sourire pour payer
sa commande
l'application même d'entreprise prix
mais que peuvent-ils de soi pour pister
des gens ne serait-ce qu'à des fins
publicitaires savoir qu'on vous répète
en donnant droit où il se trouve proche
d'un café d'une pizzeria ou d'un truc
comme ça et pouvoir vous avez une
annonce une publicité spéciale ou peu
importe
est-ce que ce banal partage de photos du
temps qui passe et donc dangereux pas
forcément mais ce soit qu'à première vue
on partage camp nou qui est très banal
est très jeune mais c'est l'accumulation
du contenu qui devient inquiétant de
toute façon ce défi des dix ans est
aussi virale que temporaire
au prochain et n'oubliez pas sur les
réseaux sociaux
si c'est gratuit c'est que vous êtes le
produit ici frédéric arnould radio
canada montréal